[Music]
there was an active shooter situation he
actually got the group around him out of
the emergency exit and then went back
into the building and went to help
whoever got shot but unfortunately the
person who got shot was dead what a
heroic husband you have right no he's
amazing
you say he's just a friend you say oh
baby you
dude shout out biz marquee that's what
that is right
yes it is yeah that's talking about
all day kelly thanks for that hey this
is dr john daloni show
we're
we are
this is this is a
a show about singing
and about great great songs manship
actually it's not at all it's the best
mental health and marriage and parenting
and family and whatever else is going on
podcast ever and i'm glad that you've
joined us if you want to be on the show
give me a buzz 1-844-693-3291
there'll be a singing audition where you
actually will sing into the recorder for
jennifer kelly and not really or go to
john
delaney.com ask and we will
get it going on let's do it let's go to
uh
how does that song go in baton rouge
colin baton rouge
i'm not going to sing
the the garth brook song yeah it's
called colin bet colin baton rouge but
i'm not gonna sing it i love that song
that will turn all of our listeners away
this then it will be one of the worst
podcasts in the history of podcast all
right let's go to matt and baton rouge
what's up dude
how's it going dr john it's uh great to
actually talk to you it's great to talk
to you you've never heard the uh do
y'all just walk around in baton rouge
sing the baton rouge song all the time
i have no idea i am a
i am a metal guy straight up i'm not a
country guy whatsoever listen i wasn't
either
i i'm with you
but then someone showed me garth brooks
and he was my gateway drug
and uh so hey go get a garth brooks
record or maybe because you were born in
the 21st century just pull up spotify
and check it out all right hey so what's
up man i have i have quite a bit of
vinyl collection myself anyways so
i need some advice on how to navigate
what i kind of feel is
a sort of
conflict or misalignment in personal
values between
myself and my girlfriend
it's causing quite a bit of tension in
our relationship and i would like for it
to not be
the end of our relationship but i'm
having trouble seeing any kind of
solution that doesn't result in
either
us breaking up or resentment for one
toward the other either way
somewhere further down the road uh
so so it's either about sex or money
which one is it
uh it's
not
i guess it's almost tangentially about
sex but not quite okay um
so basically she took a she's taken i'm
just gonna say she's taking a job that's
causing her to have to do some things
that i am uncomfortable with personally
dude you got to be more specific man
what are you talking about
all right so uh it's going to sound kind
of trivial but i'll just get into it
she's she does a lot of community
theater acting and for local productions
and whatnot and she's taking a role
that's basically required her to
basically become a stripper um
you know i understand that it's just
kind of
playing pretend and playing dress up and
telling the story and all that but
i'm still uncomfortable with the
physical reality of my girlfriend doing
some
you know getting
almost naked and doing
erotic things on stage in public for a
bunch of people i'm just i'm
uncomfortable with that okay um
and
uh the bigger issue is that when i try
to bring it up
um
try to tell her about it look i'm just
you know this is making me uncomfortable
um
it doesn't go that well it results in a
pretty big argument and
the end result is you know
hey i understand you feel this way but
this is my dream and so i'm gonna do
what i want to achieve it
okay so that's why that's why i'm kind
of so that's what kind of leads me to
the values conclusion yeah i guess yeah
yeah
but you got a very clear answer
i'm choosing this over you and it sounds
like
you don't like that answer don't want to
hear that answer and what i will tell
you is
a you're allowed to have any value you
want
okay right nobody gets a say in that and
there will be a bajillion people who
comment on youtube or whatever with this
clip comes out and they'll be like
throwing their nobody gets a vote on
your values as they're yours right okay
and when you get married with somebody
you you decide to share them okay
right but you've stated your values out
loud
i don't want um
to be connected to somebody who's gonna
show her body off in this in a public
forum right right right wrong or
indifferent that's you're one of your
values
and she has said
i
one of my values is i want to be in
theater and this is a part of being an
actress and so this is what i want
which is a roundabout way of saying this
my values are more important than yours
yeah yeah i've kind of had this
conversation over and over again in my
head and i've kind of come to that
conclusion i'm just
it's not it's not really a math problem
it's just it's just pretty direct
yeah yeah
and so what i would tell you is
never never compromise your values for a
job
for a girlfriend for a boyfriend like
when you go down that road it gets hard
so you may have heard me say on the show
all the time there's a big difference
between beliefs and values and i think
belief should be pushed and pulled
that's why i'm always i don't pose
people ask me the most common question i
get is what books are you reading and i
rarely post them
because i'm always reading things that
are diametrically opposed to the what i
already believe because i want to
pressure test my beliefs right or i want
to learn new things
when it comes to my values man um over
time i've i've gotten fewer of them
and they've expanded and they've become
more concrete does that make sense
right so how old are you now
uh 28 she's 27. okay so you got you got
a set of values right now you're going
to look back when you're 40 and be like
oh gosh those are some of my values but
the answer is yes they are
and they just are right so the question
is are you going to compromise your
values
um
or are you going to say hey this is this
is a deal breaker for me
oh
yeah yeah that's that's
i think i listened enough to the show
that i kind of that that was pretty much
the the thing i was expecting i'm just
having i guess i'm just having trouble
coming to uh
it's a hard conclusion to come to i
guess yeah um well here's why it's not a
hard conclusion
um
tell me if this math works out i'm doing
this in real time okay so i'm just i'm
thinking this as i go you you have a
core value that's about you
and about um intimacy in your
relationship right
correct
and
she has a core value about
acting
is that right yes right
so does it work tell me if i'm wrong
does it work that you are choosing
a core value
that sits within you and she is choosing
a thing over you does that work
because that's what it feels like
yeah that's you know that's and that's
what it feels like to to me too and and
i i've listened enough the show to i've
heard you say several times you know
behavior is a language and
to me
what what this is saying to me is hey my
dream is more important than you and how
you feel about it uh
and that you know that's what i'm that's
that's how i'm feeling about the
situation that's what i feel that she's
saying to me
have you said that to her have you said
that
not that specifically but i've i've said
that
um and i think
i don't
i definitely don't think that she's
specifically trying to do something that
hurts me
um i just don't think she thinks about
it in the same way that i do to me it is
an intimacy thing and
you know to me
doing that on stage that kind of thing
is a level of intimacy that i feel
should be reserved something that we
should just share between the two of us
and not something that should be shared
in public yeah and that that's what that
that's why it kind of bothers me but to
her she doesn't think of it that way to
her it's just a performance it's uh
telling a story playing a character that
kind of thing the intimacy thing and it
you know it could be that she just
doesn't you know she has a whole
different bunch of intimacy issues that
we could spend the whole show talking
about um
you know i don't know well i don't know
that i'd characterize them as issues
they're just different than yours
yeah right yeah yeah and
here's a common misconception
you can love somebody
and you can be sexually attracted to
somebody
yet have very different values
meaning that you can love somebody i've
got friends and family that i love
but good god almighty we vote
differently and we think differently
about issues and we've got very
different ways of communicating with
people and we have very different values
there's been people that i'm sexually
attracted to but we had different values
and so we didn't i didn't pursue a
long-term relation you see what i'm
saying like
yeah yeah it didn't play out in the long
term my wife and i shared the same
values when she was my girlfriend and
that's ultimately what brought us
together see what i'm saying so
those two things often like well we i
love her and i'm attracted to her and
vice versa then why can't this thing
work those two things aren't always
the bellwether here right yeah you want
to be aligned in the values um
how long have you all been dating
oh it's been it's been a couple years
now this is the first time anything like
this has has come up
my guess is
um so you've heard me talk about
pictures and words you ever talked to me
about heard me say that
uh yeah yeah okay
it wouldn't surprise me like her wanting
to be an actress
can't be a surprise right she's no no
absolutely absolutely
you know i love that about her and i
love that she's doing
it's just that this this one aspect of
it is is causing me some discomfort so
have you
ever been watching a movie
and there's nudity in the movie and you
all talk about it on the way home like
man would you ever do that or i would
never do it has that ever come up when
the two years all been been dating
it it came it came up
over this conversation um that you know
she wants to and
it was basically kind of the same thing
like look i you know i really wouldn't
be comfortable if you if you would do
some stuff like that and the response
was basically the same like look i'm
gonna do whatever i have to do to
achieve this dream uh you know
so
when it comes back to the pictures and
words
i can imagine
you've known you're dating an actress
right
and the
actress you're dating has told you
for two years this is a dream of mine
yeah y'all have used the same word but
you'll have very different pictures of
what actress meant
see what i'm saying and both of you
right now are feeling like the other
person has pulled a bait-and-switch
yeah i feel like i want her to be an
actress yeah i support you fully whoa
put your clothes back on and she's
looking at you like i told you to be an
actress and y'all just had different
pictures of what actress meant
and for her it means whatever it takes
i'll do whatever the director says so i
can get into this role
and
um for you it's
i want to reserve something that's just
ours
yeah that's that's that's fair
you hit it right on the head so i think
it's fair for you to sit down and say
start there
i get that you feel like i'm pulling a
bait and switch on you i've heard
actress for all these for for a couple
of years
and
it never even occurred to me that this
was a part of
your picture of what actress meant
and so i want you to know i'm not trying
to deceive you i'm not i i'm not trying
to as you're walking out on the stage be
like don't do that don't do that
um
and ultimately tell her i love you
and
i am or am not going to be a part of
this moving forward and what you're
doing there is you're taking full 100
ownership of your values and make no
mistake
our values will always cost us something
always
and i know this is a steep price to pay
because you love this person right you
you had plans with her right you all had
y'all y'all talked about the future
you're y'all are you're 20 years old
you're two years into this thing right
yeah yeah absolutely
here's the here's the part i'm concerned
about
one of the two of you she drops out of
the play
or
you say cool but i'm not gonna go
or you go and you squirm and it's
uncomfortable the whole time
that is man that is a
race track to resentment
and that's that's exactly what what i'm
struggling with that's the the only two
compromises i see is either you know she
stop you know she
forever now sees me as the one that
either that ruined her dream because she
you know had to
um
skip skip out on doing certain
opportunities because of me
or
you know i just go along and and you
know continue to just kind of sit by
while she does stuff that that i'm
uncomfortable with and so either way
would lead to one of us resenting one
another down the road and that's what
i'm worried about yeah i think it's a
very it's a very legitimate true worry
the path forward here though is this
please keep this in your heart and mind
these are your values
and so if it ultimately ends your
relationship if you all end up saying
this is this is as far as we go
it's been a great run i love you and i
wish you nothing but the best
here's a dif i have a different picture
of the way my life's gonna go then what
you're the way your life is gonna go
um
then so then
so be it but
don't leave angry with her
because what she's doing is the same
thing you're doing just on the other
side of the coin she's holding to her
set of values whether you agree with
them or not and we could debate that all
day long whether what she's doing is
wise or smart or good or right all those
things
the reality is though you you'll have
you have a line and she's got a line and
now you all have got a gap between the
two of you and you're both standing
behind each other's line going are you
coming over here are you coming over
here
yeah and so
the honest way the way it usually
happens is you get mad because you have
to garner the energy to do what you got
to do
[Music]
the more integris way forward is a
humble quiet vulnerable this is as far
as i can go
and i'm going to own this
see what i'm saying
yeah i'll also say this
um
this is going to help this this is one
of those things when you ask a
billionaire like what should i do and
they're like follow your passion you're
like shut up like
there's one billionaire for every
you know
ten thousand unemployed right so
take this for what for what what it what
what it's worth
there came a moment when my wife and i
we dated for i think we were dating for
three or four years of the time she was
weird still boyfriend girlfriend
and i sat down with her and said look
if all of my dreams come true
and all of your dreams come true we end
up on separate planets
and you are pursuing your dreams as hard
as you can
and i'm pursuing mine as hard as i can
and we've been trying to do this
together it's not going to work
so let's save each other the misery and
the heartache when we get there and call
it now and we broke up and it was hard
and it was one of those things that like
i thought it was right at the time i
think it was right at the time
and within the next year
what my dream for my life was shifted
radically
and hers changed to so see what i'm
saying so yeah yeah hear me say yeah
that just because you say hey this is
this is as far as i can go that doesn't
mean it's the death and the end forever
but be prepared for it to be right
right
um or
man have a hard conversation with
yourself and say no i'm okay with this
yeah but whatever it is take ownership
of it okay for sure i wish i had some
some like i wish i had some like oh no
just say this
these are hard and for everybody
watching to listen please don't just
bomb the comment section here for matt
right
i want as a culture us to get to a place
where we honor a each other's values
b we have hard discussions about why is
this your value and why is this mine and
let's engage in this conversation
and let's be integris about shaking
hands and saying hey i'm gonna go my go
my way here
i realize that my boss has different
values than me and he or she is asking
for different values of their employees
and these aren't my values and so i'm
gonna i know i just moved across the
country here i know this pays great i'm
not gonna throw grenades and try to
shift in it i i'm gonna step off and i'm
gonna go
there's a few core values that all of us
in a society have to have right we can
debate those all day long but there's
there's some core ones on treating
people with dignity and respect and
loving everybody all those things
but there's just going to be moments in
our lives when we have to be okay with
walking up and saying hey this is a
value i love you i'ma shake hands
um but it's time for me to head off in
this other direction
and i'm thinking ownership of it
so it was hard matt i'm sorry man and i
know it's hard for your girlfriend too
um the whole thing's hard and
i wish you the best let me know how that
hard conversation goes and uh i'll walk
with you every step of the way my
brother we'll be right back
hey what's up delony here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at betterhelp betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your
healing better help is customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with you and your
therapist you never have to even see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's more affordable than in-person
therapy plus you can be matched with the
therapist in under 48 hours and today
our listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
that's betterhelphelp.com
all right we're back let's go to cali in
bowling green going back to kelly what's
up
hey dr john how are you we are rocking
on to the brigadon how about you
i'm wonderful i just want to say i'm
super thankful for everything that
you've brought to our community and that
you put out there i'm one of the ogs yes
i've been listening since episode one so
yes thank you so much i'm i'm
i'm deeply grateful thank you
no problem so what's up so
um i'm calling today because i coach a
high school volleyball team and that
comes with its own challenges
we have been really struggling on
teaching our girls how to communicate
with one another
and on top of that learning to be
vulnerable on top of the communicating
piece
yeah i just wanted your advice on how to
kind of facilitate that with high school
girls
as a former high school i'm just kidding
so i thought you were about to say hey
we're struggling on offense and i was
gonna have to tell you i don't really
know how volleyball works i just know
that y'all they go in a line so good
this one's an easier question for me to
answer
um
and i used to be a high school coach too
and it's one of my favorite jobs i've
ever ever had so good for you are you
enjoying it do you like
the influence in their life
i absolutely love it i have a full-time
job year-round but this is something
that i also do year-round we coach high
school
from july to october and then i turn
around and coach club ball for the same
high school girls um from december until
may
they're never in
yeah exactly okay so here's what i've
seen and working with high school and
college kids over the last couple
decades i've seen in a way that i don't
think most adults most 35 and 45 year
olds and and older
fully grasp
just how much
relationship has moved on into digital
exchanges
like even asking like my middle schooler
and his all his friends like when you go
with somebody right you give a
girlfriend
you never even make eye contact you
don't see each other it's all texts and
photos and emojis like everything's been
outsourced there and so you're getting a
lot of information but
it's it's interesting i haven't talked
to a high school coach but it doesn't
surprise me that then when they get in a
real life situation where they have to
basically read each other's minds and
know i'm going to be here in this space
and you got to look at my body position
and i've got to holler at you and say
hey go go go
their brains don't just shut down right
so give me an example of of
situations where there's
they're not being vulnerable where they
need to communicate better
give me an example that
so i'll kind of give you a little bit of
a background um
last season this is probably the most
talented group i've ever coached hands
down they're very young
primarily sophomores
we have a few seniors that kind of lead
the group but even some of them are
struggling with communication
um
but we've
started working with a sports
psychologist last year she did wonderful
work
but we of course were unable to afford
her this year high school budget
volleyball doesn't make that cut way to
go america
very very much so so i've kind of tried
to step in that role and start doing
some small and large group activities
with them after practice
just to learn to communicate off the
court hoping that it will transfer onto
the court
so on the court they're just having
issues where they literally will not
talk
to each other they're running into each
other something will happen
and ss coaches feel like we're having to
spoon feed them everything to say and do
gotcha and they are physically capable
of knowing exactly what to do and what
to say but
um it's just that awkwardness that
tension and even
um some of the small group activities
we've been doing with them
after practice
to get them to open up to each other to
even say something they like about
themselves
it's like
terrible it's so awkward yeah
do not feel comfortable whatsoever
um
okay so let's
back all the way out ultimately there's
two things at play one there's trust and
one there is just a skill set okay
i do believe that we're gonna have hell
to pay because we're gonna have a
generation of people that don't have the
skills to communicate in person with one
another
right and i think we're you're you're
experiencing like i don't even know how
to tell you that i'm uncomfortable i can
text it to you i can dm you let you know
how i'm feeling
but i can't say that to you right and
for you and me who's grew up saying it
first and texting it second
that feels insane but that's the reality
right
the second one is trust and here's
i think you earn trust three one of
three ways if not all three
play
sharing meals
and shared experiences
i've gotta know you're gonna be there
and i have to have these um exchanges
over food over play
that is gonna allow me to then my brain
to feel safe enough to say hey i don't
think i look good in this or i don't
like the way you talk to me on the court
right so i've got to set a context and
so i'd love to
reframe it
and these aren't adjunct things so even
the language like we do these things
after practice
i would love for you to include them
into practice
this is a part of who we are
um and i'm thinking back to little
things that my coaches have made like we
had a weekly
team dinner during season
um where we'd all get together um i'm
gonna send you every single deck of
questions for humans that i got okay
that would be amazing thank you so much
i even i started a break i have
breakfast with my son once a week and
we're doing a book exchange and stuff
i even took them with me this last week
and they were they're a blast i'd
forgotten that i'd written some of these
questions out but we had a great time
but it allowed a different level of
conversation between me and my son
when you have a deck of cards like that
when you have some sort even if you just
go find an app i'm sure there's a
million apps out there
when you
you can point to the question ask the
car the deck of cards asks the question
not you and it makes it safer for some
reason okay it depersonalizes it in a
way but what i would recommend is saying
okay from this point forward
we're gonna cut practice short on
thursdays
by 30 minutes
because they're good right what they
need to do is learn to talk and trust
and that's going to help accelerate
their connectivity as they function as a
single unit on the court
and but i'm going to ask you to stay 30
minutes longer than you normally would
and we're going to have a team dinner
and whether that's pizza or whether
that's spaghetti i think we should do
spaghetti dinners and the parents made
it and brought it and sometimes it was
good and sometimes it was a disaster
and but we shared that experience
here's another thing have you tried to
go first
i have how's that going i told them that
i
firmly believe in leading
by example good for you anytime that i
ask them a question i answer it first
um and i've
you know probably admitted things opened
up about things that i typically
wouldn't in front of myself
but i feel like they need to see that
and they need to see a coach be
vulnerable yes
my problem is i'm only an assistant i'm
one of four coaches okay and their head
coach is a male and he's a very good
friend of mine
and he
would never participate in this
so i guess that's a two-fold i
i'm the only one kind of steer heading
this and i've got a great relationship
with the girls because of it
but to get him and the other coaches
involved
is a challenge of its own
why won't he play
um he
just full honesty comes off with his job
is to win games yep okay which i
understand um but
i do too
i feel like you have to connect that's
exactly right so he's playing a very
short game right he's like a modern
corporation that's like i got to make
more earnings in this quarter and they
forget that they're playing a long game
right and so you can earn you can sprint
and sprint and sprint eventually your
company's gonna go away very similar
um he's gonna win some games out of some
talented kids and he's gonna move on to
a new place and lead these kids there um
that's hard okay i wish there was an
easy i've worked with head coaches
they're hard it's hard there's a lot of
ego there there's a lot of this is my
team and that language right this is my
group of humans that i
run and own and whatever um that's gonna
be hard i think the best you can do is
just be the positive influence that you
can and it might would he be a part
would he support team dinners would he
support team play or cut and practice
short or does it all have to be
something you do after he gets done with
his practice
um i think i could convince him we're
really like we went to college together
we're close friends so
he's very stubborn but i can probably
get through to him eventually okay okay
um runners is definitely something we
could do here's here's where team
dinners are important
on thursdays we do team dinners there
are no electronics allowed none zero
everyone's gonna make it
um on monday
it for as a warm-up or the first thing
we do
we're gonna do some crazy agility drill
that is team driven
coaches will not participate there's an
over coaching that's happening with
young young
athletes also
that every move is prescriptive
this idea that there's going to go play
then we don't do that anymore because we
got to win games and by winning games
i'm going to give you this play you got
to run this play in this way
and
so they literally don't know how to take
a next step because every step has been
prescribed for them since they were
three years old
and there's something about letting them
just go we're gonna give you five
minutes so y'all figure this game out
and this is how this game works and
here's the four coaches and we're gonna
demonstrate how it goes and y'all are
competing against this other you know
the you know the a squad is going to
participate against the or compete
against the b squad we're going to make
them do some of these things but we're
not going to over coach them we're going
to back out a little bit
okay and i was the worst
the
worst this is the pot talking the kettle
here
man
every mistake my first year of coaching
every mistake i called out
you threw the ball away you did it and
it rem
after my first year i had some coaches
lean into me a little bit because i was
a young hot-headed knuckle-headed [ __ ]
and they said dude
you know who knows that they just
dribbled that ball off their knee into
the stands
more than anybody that kid
you yelling it across the uh gym isn't
helpful
he knows you know what i mean
right and that was such a good reminder
especially in practice to
dial back my coaching and dial up my
engagement
meaning i'm gonna be much more
relational and less i see that when i
see that when i see that you see what
i'm saying i'm gonna coach effort i'm
gonna coach spacing i'm gonna coach
paying attention much more than move
over left go up you see what i'm saying
right and i don't know if that's going
on in your practices that sure went on
in my practice man because i i was just
over coaching and i paralyzed the kids
when i did that and by the way if you're
listening to this you're not a coach all
of this applies to parenting
we over parent and we over like hey you
got this you do this you got this you do
this you got your deodorant you brush
your teeth did you get your shoes get
today just today
my son left his track shoes his
cross-country shoes
and inside and i asked my wife as i was
leaving me run these to the school it's
20 minutes out of the way this way and i
got to go 20 minutes back she said no
he'll just have to do practice in
whatever shoes he's wearing
and that's probably going to be a very
uncomfortable three mile run in the
woods
and i assure you he's gonna remember his
shoes right this is just the way we move
forward right
oh man all right so kelly hang on the
line here i'm gonna send you all of the
questions for humans cards and by the
way if you have people in your life
whether they're teens adults um
couples you just started dating you've
been dating a long time you've been
married a long time
there's cards for everybody girls night
guys night friends just hanging out
having chips in queso and having a few
beers whatever it is
grab these cards they're tools to teach
us again how to have in-person
communication how to have in-person
conversations and man all over the
planet people are writing and saying
these things are changing their families
and changing their friendships
go pick some up johnalon.com we'll be
right back
all right we are back let's go to anne
in san antonio what's up ann
hi how are you i'm good and you
i'm pretty good pretty good hot in texas
is it still a thousand degrees
yes has it rained yet
um we got the
god the tear it like a small
sprinkle of a rain it was at such tease
the clouds rolled in
everything looked good there was
lightning and then it rained for two
minutes and stopped it was awful there's
just like a bunch of people spitting in
the front yard and that's about it i'm
sorry that's what it felt like and hey
here's what's here's everyone that i
know in texas is waiting for
it will all catch up in a weekend and
then flood everything right so it'll be
like oh we need 10 inches of rain here
which is the annual average let's do it
on a wednesday at four right and then
anyway i'm sorry
how can i help i wish i was a
meteorologist i just can't do anything
about
know it's all right
what's up
my husband
um last week he went to our his local
gym
and there was an active shooter
situation
and he saw everything he saw the person
be murdered
oh it's an active shooter it wasn't
somebody just pulled a gun
to get shot okay
yes someone got shot okay yeah
and he witnessed everything
um thankfully his job is in on thread
assessment he didn't follow the crowd
um he actually got the group around him
out of the emergency exits you know
because he takes a mental map of
everywhere he goes right and then went
back into the building um once the
shooter he didn't see the shooter
anymore and went to help whoever got
shot
but unfortunately the person who got
shot was dead yeah
i'm so sorry man what a heroic husband
you have right
no he's amazing yeah
were you at the gym
no but i'm just going on my intuition
for whatever reason that day yeah um
uh here's what here's what i'm asking
i'm asking you're wearing this heavily
yeah
how's it how are you wearing it
are you are you that i almost lost my
husband or i could have lost my husband
he was right there is that close or
i'm heartbroken and worried that he saw
this and went through this like where's
your heart on this
i think all of it yeah
especially that's the gym i told him not
to go to
i told you shows aren't the super best
way to approach this but it's not and i
definitely did not and when he called me
he's like hey don't freak out i'm like
okay
sure
listen let me just take a side here
good people of the podcast land
especially you gentlemen
don't ever call someone you love
especially your wife and say
start the call with hey don't freak out
don't do that
because that's a recipe for a total
freak out okay that was just my public
service announcement back to you anne
okay
so your husband saw some hard stuff
what's it been like since then
um he tends to hold things in so that's
why i'm concerned
um he came back he came back home and he
tried to play it off you know try to
have some dark humor in it
but i you know we are both in the marine
corps together
and that's where we met so i already you
know seen it we have a lot of friends
who are unfortunately committed suicide
and that's where my mind is going
okay
that you're worried that because he
experienced this ultimately it's going
to lead to him taking his
taking his life dying by suicide
um i think i don't know if it would ever
go there but you know when i did bring
up you know you know maybe you should
get some counseling maybe there's
someone you can talk to
um he said no outright and
no i think that's stupid and useless and
i think it's because of our friends who
have gone through
the type of system and it didn't help
yeah
okay
so here's what i want you to do in this
situation here's a couple of things okay
number one
um i know you're a veteran i know you're
a marine or you've seen a lot of stuff
i want you to take ownership of your
trauma involved here secondary traumatic
stress is a real thing
okay
and trauma's cumulative it adds up over
time
and so it might be un it might feel
weird that this is affecting you so much
and you aren't even there
but here's the thing
it just piles onto your body on top of
the other traumas you've experienced
firsthand or vicariously
okay so trauma's cumulative you've heard
me talk about the backpack you've you're
if your backpack's already filled to the
brim and someone just rests a brick on
it at some point it all falls over okay
that's where you are right now
so don't think you're crazy because you
can't stop thinking about this and you
weren't even there okay
but i want you to take ownership that
this is your trauma
because it's easy for you to feel
unmoored and untethered and not well and
then to dump all of that on him and his
lack of response and he's not responding
in a way that you think he should be
responding after going through a really
harrowing situation
okay
i will tell you personally
and i'm going to go ahead and just give
a warning here to anybody listening if
there's little ears in the room
you probably want to have them head out
okay
so ann
i've been in situations where i've seen
the insides of people's bodies on the
outside you too have you two
yes unfortunately okay
and
it's very very different than the movies
right
yeah
and when you're watching a movie you
don't smell
and you don't have to watch your hands
and where you're stepping and where
you're leaning right so i'm getting real
graphic here but here's what i'm trying
to tell you i've been there and as a as
almost as a meta
i've been really surprised at how it
didn't affect me like i thought it would
to the point that i went and saw a
counselor because i thought i was a
psychopath
where it did affect me though
so i didn't shut me down i gallow's
humor is how i handle that stuff and so
um it was some real dark dark humor
making jokes that were inappropriate um
and my circle of friends got pretty
tight because there's a few only a few
people i could talk to about it
where it came out was i got real short
with people that i loved or i wasn't
sleeping very good which over time made
me
uh or encouraged me open up an avenue
where i made some poor diet choices
which then right so it affected me in
weird ways but not in the ways i would
have thought okay
here's why that's important for you
don't put your
picture of how he should be handling
this on to him that's going to cause a
division in your relationship
what i'd much rather you do is sit down
with him and say
i'm going to go talk to somebody because
this is affecting me
i'm taking ownership of my mental health
and wellness i'm a call local counselor
i need you to promise me that if you're
not okay you will reach out
okay
and
here's another important one and my wife
has been a gift here she has
not like we don't talk like when i was
doing christ like i wouldn't talk about
what i saw i wouldn't bring that stuff
up that wasn't fair to come back from a
scene and then just dump that on her
but she sure did call out hey you're
really having energy about you that
you're looking for a fight
and it's making me uncomfortable i'd be
like i'm not looking for a fight and she
goes i know but i just need you to you
are radioactive or i can tell the last
five nights you haven't slept all night
you're tossing and turning and so she
called out my behavior she didn't try to
armchair diagnose me she didn't tell me
i was doing something wrong she didn't
tell me i was screwing something up she
did call out my behavior as someone who
loves me and who spends a lot of time
with me do you get the difference there
yeah and i didn't do anything i just
mention it just like hey and
i did mention it to him like hey maybe
if there's someone you talk to and you
know it was out of his behavior and i
said it just like that not pushing it on
him or anything is real patient and i
only brought it up once and let it go
okay so what he was already what's his
behavior not
he's usually a happy-go-lucky guy i mean
he's very
approachable everybody really really
loves him and that's kind of why i was
concerned because i do see his behavior
changing he said it doesn't affect him
but i do catch a glimpse like i do pay
attention to him
to where a couple days after it happened
he was just staring off into space even
the the night it happened he was just
staring off into space and i didn't push
it i didn't pressure him and the first
one of the first things they did was you
know after he said you don't want to
counseling i reached out to his a couple
of his best friends and
let them know what happened and just
said hey you know
i don't want you to be caught off guard
if he does need to talk to somebody
like he does as of right now he doesn't
want to do you know talk to a counselor
or anything like that like and he
seemed like he would like he was okay
about it but i
knew since my older sister also has ptsd
who's that's gone untreated we're
dealing with her rage fits and
everything too and that but here's the
thing let's deal with the behavior not
with the pseudo-diagnosis okay
yeah so if you see him staring off into
space and one of the things
it's funny you mentioned that because
that's exactly what my wife would call
out she would say you're here but you're
not here and she would just say it very
quietly hey you're with us but you're
not with us
or she would say come back to us that
was her quiet thing and she would do it
very gently and quietly and she'd put
her hand on me like she would touch my
hand or touch my leg and say
hey come back to us and we would do that
at a dinner party and i would just be
staring off into space didn't even
realize i'd left the room and i had okay
it wasn't
hey you need to go to see a counselor
and you because your depression's it
wasn't that because that would have
walled me off i would have said i'm not
i'm fine i'm completely fine i'm sitting
here at dinner laughing i'm having a
good time
it was
hey come back to us
and
you promise you will call if if you feel
like something's going south if you feel
like you're hurting yourself
uh yes i promise that's it i'm not going
to try to armchair diagnose you i'm
going to call it behavior hey you're
getting really loud and really angry i'm
not okay with that i'm gonna take the
kid and i'm gonna i'm gonna leave
because this is me you see what i'm
saying we're talking about the behavior
not the diagnosis and not the solution
we're gonna let them
find their path towards that solution
okay
and if you see something troubling
like all of a sudden guns are out more
than they usually are or
he's starting to give stuff away to some
stuff that is his prized possessions or
he starts getting throwing things away
um he starts talking about
missing some of his friends who died by
suicide if if you start getting nervous
then you call everyone you know right
you called everybody
but this sounds to me
like you are struggling with this and i
want you to take ownership of what
you're struggling with okay
are you there
i'm here yeah will you do that
i can why won't you
you're not going to i know you're not i
know you're not i know i have a lot of
friends who are tough veterans you're
not going to why won't you
and just pretend we're having a beer and
some nachos and i'm just sitting across
the table from you this isn't me like
talking down at you like i'm smiling
like why why won't you
i have other things to worry about like
what
um we just moved to the area one thing
um we have a six-year-old kid trying to
get him
adjusted to a new moving place where
you're here based kind of alone
yep
um
my husband travels for work
okay
so most of the time i'm holding it don't
mess whole
yep i have a chance to worry about
you sound tired
i'm exhausted
so let me tell you the single greatest
gift you could give your
is this a six-year-old little boy or a
little girl
he's a boy okay
the single greatest gift you could give
your little boy and the single greatest
gift you could give your husband is
connection
not that they're getting a performance
not that they're getting a
shell of you
but that they're fully getting you
and so what that means is the greatest
gift you could give your son and the
greatest gift you could give your
husband is to get well
because the evil of trauma is that it
disconnects us from relationship
because other people die other people
hurt us
and so other people become the thing our
body tries to protect us from and
unfortunately it's the only thing that
keeps us well as other people
see you see how it's a mess
yep
and you're exhausted and now you're real
lonely too right
yeah
yeah i feel like i take care of everyone
around me and i kind of just you do i
don't
don't go to the doctor unless
um my leg's falling off
and
that's not brave
it's good it's dumb
it's just dumb
it's efficient for everyone else but
myself it's not though
you're giving them 65
they deserve more of you
and they can only get more of you if you
will get well
yeah i i agree
have you seen hard hard stuff
like what
in terms of death and
some of that carnage that comes along
with that
um i have
but i also
i did take your ace to score i'm a nine
that's what i was getting this is test
score yes
often those of us who find ourselves in
helping roles are helping because we
have to
right
yeah
yeah
i would love love love
for you to be at your six-year-old's
wedding
and i would love love
love
for you to be that crazy
crazy san antonio grandma
for his little knuckleheaded kids he's
gonna have
well that's what i tell my husband all
the time i'm like when i'm old i just
want to sit on a front porch with a
hound dog and throw pine cones at people
walking by oh gosh we're the same person
dude i've had basset hounds my whole
life and as soon as my last as soon as
josephine goes to college i'm getting
more hound dogs they're disgusting and
gross and loud and i love them
yes but here's the thing
that picture you have to reverse
engineer just like a mission here's our
objective and so what do we have to do
starting today to make that happen
and so you're playing a long game and
right now you are caught in a common
trauma response which is i just need to
get to the next hour and then the next
hour and then the next hour and then i
collapse at night usually i take
something to go to sleep and then i prop
myself up with chemicals when i wake up
and i start the whole thing over again
and i want you to start playing a longer
game here
okay and that starts with you calling a
counselor in san antonio and saying i'm
new to the area my aces score is a nine
and i'm ready to go to work
on me
and you're probably gonna have to take a
yoga class you probably have to get
massage you're gonna have to learn what
good touch and healthy touch is you're
gonna have to learn
how to write in journal you have to
learn all this new crap
it's gonna be like come on man
yeah i mean i do
um mixed martial arts and maybe my
husband just started dance lessons
because i didn't want to miss i don't
want a disconnection to happen
a lot of us outside our comfort zone
keeps us close connected so we have no
choice too genius genius i love it
love love love it
and the last true
intimate connection is two former
marines
getting past the wall
and
being
emotionally vulnerable and intimate when
it comes to what i'm thinking and what
my needs are
and what i love and what i want to do
one day yeah and it's basically been
us
the entire time we've moved every moved
everywhere together we got married
number 18. yep it was just just
it's just been us yeah and
we
yeah it's just it's been us looking out
for each other
i know but you're looking out for each
other in a performative way
you're not with each other you're trying
to protect each other
so you see the difference
yes yeah we're protecting each other
that's exactly and you get in this weird
circle he wakes up and feels that you're
a hundred miles away from him even
though you're three inches away from him
in bed and he sets off to protect you
and help how is he gonna do that he's no
one to shoot anymore and so he's gonna
go earn a bunch of money
and he's gonna he's gonna do what he's
gotta do because he's just gonna follow
the script on how to take care of a wife
in texas
and you're going to wake up and realize
husband just took off again to another
town to another job to another thing
and i need to protect him because he's
going to be busy he's going to be doing
these things and so i'm going to get a
bunch of tasks
and he's going to get a bunch of tasks
and a bunch of jobs
and none of that will address
are you with me
yes and i think a lot of it too is that
we both come from a similar background
so we're kind of dedicated ourselves to
changing
our
the changing cycles awesome that's i
mean that's amazing it's amazing
that's incredible
if i sent you two copies of
on your past change of future would you
all read them together
i already have it you got it have you
read it yeah
um it's in my audible i'm actually on
chapter three okay
um
stay on the line i'm gonna send you two
hard copies you can audible it too but
if y'all will go through that together
it will give you something to point at
yeah and there's a few chapters in there
he can roll his eyes at and be like oh
this is so dumb
yeah that's exactly what he's gonna do
of course he is and you can just laugh
and you can tell him to call me don't
call me we could roll our eyes together
it's fine
um okay but
it will give you an entry point too what
do you think about that
and what do you think about that
and i think this is stupid why do you
think that's stupid
and it gives you an entry point into a
conversation okay
i'm sorry that he experienced this i'm
so glad he was there
to save a bunch of people's lives and
i'm glad he's got you to come home and
anchor into
yeah we balance each other really well
you do
yes we balance each other really well
where he's weak i'm strong or i'm strong
he's weak and
i want to introduce you to a life not on
the teeter-totter
yeah
where it doesn't have to balance
right where it's like
just
saying that out loud just now
that's such a military of course it is
the way you solve problems oh my god
oh my god hey hold on there's some
greatness to that you have a framework
that most people walking on the street
don't have
and here's the thing you've heard me say
this a million times on the show
the framework that keeps you alive
can be the framework in a different
time and period at a time
the things that you do to keep you alive
when you're a kid or the things that are
going to blow your marriage up the
things that you do in the military the
way you solve problems the way you have
to have step-by-step instructions so
that we can get this mission
that is amazing
and if the strategies in the plan become
more important than your wife or your
husband when you're newlyweds trying to
figure out life outside of the military
it can become constrictive right so
don't throw that stuff out you may laugh
and catch and be like oh sound like i'm
in the military again that's fine
he's lucky to have you
and my hope for you guys is this y'all
are doing they are amazing amazing
my hope is
that y'all can say hey
we are doing all of these things
he is all in on loving you and you are
all in on loving him and you're both all
in on taking care of that kid and you
it's common you're taking the line share
the work and you're exhausted and you're
running and you're running and you're
lonely in a new town all those things
my dream for you is that you
would say hey i'm going to stop driving
at 95 miles an hour i'm going to back it
down to 60 55 and put on cruise control
for a while
i'm gonna go sit down and say some
things out loud for the first time in my
life about what life was when i was a
kid the things i've been through the
things i've seen things i've experienced
in the military and it's gonna be
uncomfortable and it's gonna be gnarly
and i'm gonna learn some new skills and
i'm gonna process some old traumas so
that
i will be the most present wife the most
present mom i will be the most at peace
my body will be at peace
so that those i love can anchor and
repel off the side
and husband by the way i want you to do
that too
that may be a harder sell but um
[Music]
often learn by watching so and go first
you're brave
so grateful for you and your husband and
your service and your gifts to our
communities
and i'll walk with you every step of the
way as you all head into the new
into the new whatever right wherever it
goes we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloney.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show uh
man that was
some heavy stuff today go out and do
something nice go serve somebody um go
find someone to laugh with
uh go for a walk
um go find beauty
um today's song of the day is based off
the first call the t-pain classic i'm in
love with just kidding it's not it's
actually um space hog
my good buddy chad came into the studio
mind to go and he's like i thought of
this song when i thought of you and i
don't know if whether to think that's a
good thing or a bad thing most people
don't think
delony
kind of like a space hog but the song is
in the meantime and it goes like this
and in the end we shall achieve in time
the thing they call divine and all the
stars will smile for me when all is well
and well is all for all and forever
after maybe in the meantime
we love the all the all of you where
lands are green and skies are
blue we're all in all we're just like
you we love all of you
that's about right i love you guys we'll
see you soon